it's about my old self and breaking up
with my old self and my addiction and my
alcoholism Demi lavato is on the road to
recovery and a source tells ET she's
committed to her sobriety it's just
about you know not going back to those
old ways that I always resorted to
because it doesn't do it for me anymore
following her reported overdose last
year our source says dummies cut ties
with everyone on her team and she's not
spending time with people who enabled
her
the source does say Demi's recovery
hasn't been easy though quote she's hit
a couple bumps in the road and had to
return to the inpatient facility for
short stints but for the past 30 days
she has been on her own and doing really
well sometimes I'll still struggle with
past behaviors kind of and cravings
creeping in but you know that's when I
reach out to the people around me and
they're very supportive very caring and
they just remind me of who I am how
strong I am and kind of recharges my
confidence and myself and you know I
feel better the stores also says she's
eager to commit full-time to her career
quote Demi is really inspired and
feeling excited to get back on stage
and I went through some challenges and
some obstacles and I felt like at a
period of time I probably wasn't gonna
work again but as I overcame those
struggles it actually gave me more of a
I found my purpose there that all fans
have been speculating Demi could join
the Jonas Brothers on stage and some
capacity following their reunion and our
source says that's very much a
possibility though nothing is confirmed
one thing we do know Demi and the Joe
Broz go way back
well the Jonas Brothers I've said a
million times I rock them and working
with them is like working with you know
your friends it's cool
[Music]